in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Nathan
and Brooke are with us hey how are you
welcome welcome good to have you
where're you guys from my friend the
Chicago area oh very fun well good to
have you thanks for coming down to do
your debt-free scream now tell me how
much have you paid off we've paid off
$60,000 Wow and how long did that take
it took us three years three years and
making what kind of money well it
started with me so I was only making
$30,000 at the moment yeah that's what
you were making yeah that's well because
I started this journey on my own and
then you came in oh and then you got
married okay okay and what do you what's
your household income now at sixty
thousand and how long have you been
married
um only a year and four months okay so
about half of the time you've been
working this together and about half the
time you were working it by yourself
what kind of debt was the 60,000 um it
was a little bit everything this card
day it was house that a little bit and
then some credit cards and school okay
cool
Nathan what do you do for a living I
work in Tyndale House Publishing and no
warehouse oh very cool yeah and what
about you Brooke I work for the same
company but I work in the composition
Department oh very cool both for Tyndale
good publisher all right good fun
publish some great books out of there
over the years over a lot of years as a
matter of fact and I've had several
friends that have used them well good
for you guys congratulations so what
started you on this journey Brooke 36
months ago um I was in Las Vegas at a
family wedding and um Austin my bank
account was empty oh yes not because I
was gambling either
um but someone had taken six thousand
dollars out of my account and that's all
I had in my savings account
woah oh yes did you ever forget that
fixed um no cuz the police could not go
after the person that stole it oh my
goodness
so it started spiraling next thing I
know I was
and deep debt and deep trouble with the
bank and so but the bank was very
gracious right and then how did you how
did you turn it around what's the
journey of you getting out of it was my
mom she goes to Willow Creek mm-hmm and
so she had heard about your program and
she signed me up and signed herself up
and we started getting out of debt
together oh cool so you started at
Willow Creek Church yeah I've spoken
there several times and pastor hobbles
is a friend and they've had a large
percentage of their congregations gone
through Financial Peace University
that's very cool so Nathan had she
already gone through this class before
you guys got married yes she did okay
all right cool so you're on board though
you're right there with her huh yep all
right good good all right Nathan and
Brooke from Chicago Illinois proud of
you Brooke way to go $60,000 paid off in
36 months making 30 up to 60,000 a year
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three two one
excellent very well done congratulations